muchos nos habéis pedido un vídeo sobre
las protestas de colombia y creo de
verdad que os vamos a sorprender hemos
tardado varias semanas en sacarlo porque
hemos tenido ver todas las aristas de
este problema y hoy vamos a hablar de
impuestos de la policía colombiana y de
algo que seguro que muchos de vosotros
incluso los que veáis este vídeo desde
colombia no conoceréis la llamada
'doctrina damasco a que me estoy
refiriendo y que tiene que ver todo esto
con esta historia al final del vídeo lo
entenderéis vamos con nuestra historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
colombia es un país con dos caras por
desgracia todos conocemos la mala es
decir los narcos del terrorismo y la
pobreza sin embargo existe otra cara
mucho mejor veréis colombia es una de
las economías más estables de toda
latinoamérica por ejemplo colombia nunca
ha experimentado hiperinflación
[Música]
y tienen el mejor historial crediticio
de todo latinoamérica desde el año 1930
el gobierno de colombia siempre ha
devuelto sus deudas
[Música]
y si ya sé lo que estaréis pensando a
ver fonseca tampoco es que sea algo muy
bueno no es que sean noticias
espectaculares pues si tenéis razón pero
recordad que estamos hablando de un país
latinoamericano es decir que comparado
con venezuela argentina brasil o incluso
mexico podemos decir que colombia no
está tan mal sin embargo todo esto ha
cambiado con el coronavirus colombia ha
sido uno de los países más afectados del
mundo no solo en pérdidas humanas sino
también económicas en este contexto el
gobierno ha subido los impuestos y esta
subida de impuestos ha provocado
protestas y lo que podría haber sido una
protesta sin más ha terminado en una
auténtica catástrofe atentos
[Música]
y eleva a 47 los muertos en las
protestas contra el presidente duque y
aquí entra el debate que tienen ahora
los colombianos unos dicen que la
policía colombiana es ultra violenta
otros dicen que son los manifestantes lo
realmente violentos incluso algunos
políticos colombianos como el
expresidente álvaro uribe han llegado a
decir que hay grupos terroristas
infiltrados en la protesta así que la
pregunta que nos hacemos es quién tiene
razón porque iván duque el presidente de
colombia quiere subir los impuestos y
por qué es tan importante la doctrina
damasco en esta historia hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
antes os tengo que hablar de la tan
política veréis muchos nos pedís que
hablemos más sobre latinoamérica y por
eso hemos sacado nuestro propio boletín
especializado en geopolítica de
latinoamérica
por sólo 5 dólares al mes es decir lo
dispuesto a un menú bismark en bogotá
recibiréis tres correos electrónicos
todas las semanas con nuestros análisis
sobre geopolítica en latinoamérica
en latam polític descubriréis muchas
cosas de las que a duras penas se hablan
en los medios convencionales
por ejemplo descubriréis todos los
detalles de la pugna entre china y eeuu
por los recursos de brasil o porque
rusia tiene tanto interés en argentina
dicho de otra forma que si os
suscribirse a la tan política no sólo
estáis apoyando a visual política sino
que también federation información muy
difícil de encontrar en otros medios de
comunicación tenéis todos los detalles
en latam polític puntocom ahora sí vamos
a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el agujero tras la pandemia os voy a
hacer una pregunta ya sea seguro que muy
pocos vais a saber responderme cuánta
gente paga impuestos de la renta en
colombia
hablamos de uno de los países más
poblados de toda latinoamérica tienen
una población que supera los 50 millones
de habitantes pues bien cuántos de ellos
pagan impuestos de la reina
y veréis en el año 2020 hablamos sólo de
1,6 millones de personas y diréis en
serio pero cómo es posible vámonos a
colombia ya pues no pues si alguno
estaba pensando la respuesta no es ni
los impuestos bajos ni el fraude veréis
la mayoría de los países en
latinoamérica tienen dos problemas muy
importantes pobreza y economía sumergida
para que os hagáis una idea el 67 por
ciento de los colombianos ganan menos de
140 euros al mes además se calcula que
el 54 por ciento de toda la economía
colombiana es informal y si en ese 54
por ciento es donde estarían todos los
narcos quien tristemente famoso este
país
a todo esto hay que sumarle la
corrupción política que se lleva miles
de millones de dólares cada año como os
podéis imaginar en esta situación es muy
difícil recaudar impuestos por las vías
convencionales
y diréis entonces de dónde saca el
dinero el estado colombiano pues
básicamente de dónde puede como no
pueden ponerle impuestos a la renta
colombia tiene uno de los impuestos al
consumo más altos de toda latinoamérica
casi todos los productos de consumo
están gravados al 19% por otro lado
colombia también tiene un impuesto de
sociedades muy alto altísimo nacho vidal
ya no para que os hagáis una idea las
empresas formales pueden llegar a pagar
hasta un 71,9 por ciento de impuestos de
sociedades por comparar el tipo general
de impuestos de sociedades en españa
está en el 25 por ciento como os podéis
imaginar esto es un problema por un lado
el gobierno de bando que quiere bajar
los impuestos a las empresas para
intentar crear nuevos sectores
económicos por el otro necesita buscar
otras formas nuevas de recaudar dicho de
otra forma que colombia arrastra un
problema fiscal desde hace décadas sin
embargo dentro de lo que cabe colombia
era más o menos capaz de cuadrar las
cuentas hasta que llegó la pandemia y
como ha ocurrido en todos los países del
mundo la factura del coronavirus es de
todo menos barata
[Música]
el gasto público durante la pandemia en
colombia asciende a 34 6 billones de
pesos para que os hagáis una idea esos
30 y 46 millones de pesos y si hablamos
de millones en castellano equivalen a
más de 9 mil millones de dólares y esto
es solo el principio porque colombia va
a tener que gastar mucho más dinero en
asistencia sanitaria y ayudas económicas
y diréis de dónde van a sacar el dinero
pues principalmente emitiendo bonos de
deuda el problema
el problema está aquí
la colombiana ya se está vendiendo como
'bono basura' los intereses del bono de
deuda colombiana no paran de subir es
decir que cuanto más dinero han prestado
al mercado más intereses se comprometen
a pagar que puede hacer el gobierno de
iván duque para evitar todo esto pues
simple y llanamente recaudar más en
forma de impuestos de esta forma el
estado tendrá que pedir menos deuda para
que os hagáis una idea el gobierno
necesita subir la recaudación en seis
mil ochocientos cincuenta millones de
dólares y esto explica medidas como ésta
tú que trata de impulsar una nueva
reforma tributaria en colombia y diréis
pero cómo se pueden subir impuestos en
un país como colombia pues veréis el
plan de edu que se basa en tres patas
por un lado quiere bajar los impuestos a
las empresas sobre todo a las
tecnológicas lo que él llama la economía
naranja esto tiene bastante lógica de
cara al crecimiento económico y diréis
para ver con secano se supone que eduque
lo que quiere hacer es aumentar la
recaudación pues sí y aquí es donde
viene la parte más controvertido
un lado duque quiere subir los impuestos
a las clases medias
hasta ahora solo pagaban impuestos sobre
la renta las personas que cobraban más
de cuatro millones setecientos mil pesos
colombianos es decir unos mil doscientos
dólares pues bien con esta reforma se
empezaría a pagar impuestos de la renta
a partir de los dos millones trescientos
mil pesos es decir unos seiscientos
dólares
pero esperad un momento porque su plan
no se queda aquí como decíamos colombia
tiene uno de los impuestos al consumo
más altos de toda latinoamérica sin
embargo hay un montón de productos que
tienen reducciones pues bien y bando que
quiere subir casi todos por ejemplo los
ordenadores tenían un impuesto ha
reducido y ahora pasarían a tener un
tipo general del 19 por ciento productos
básicos como leche huevos que antes
estaban libres de impuestos ahora
tendrían un 5 por ciento de tributación
y como os podéis imaginar aquí es donde
llega la gran polémica porque casi todos
estos impuestos afectan principalmente a
las clases medias y a las clases bajas y
esto es lo que provocó las primeras
protestas y diréis qué ha pasado después
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
el debate equivocado da igual si la
reforma fiscal de duke era buena o era
mala porque digo que da igual pues
porque tras las primeras protestas el
gobierno ya la ha retirado atentos
[Música]
de las protestas y retira la reforma
tributaria de colombia habéis oído bien
el gobierno ha escuchado los
manifestantes ya ha propuesto un diálogo
con los principales sindicatos para
sacar otra reforma fiscal distinta sin
embargo en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo colombia sigue teniendo
protestas y diréis por qué protestan
ahora pues en parte por eso de que ha
escuchado a los manifestantes entre
comillas los sindicatos con los que se
ha reunido solo representan a una
minoría muy concreta de los
manifestantes pero en realidad la
principal razón por la que continúan las
protestas es esto
colombia eleva a 47 los muertos en las
protestas contra el presidente duque
habéis oído bien en el momento lo que
hacemos este vídeo hay más de 47 civiles
asesinados por la policía y 800 heridos
la policía antidisturbios colombiana el
terrible es maf ha llegado a torturar a
muchos de los manifestantes pero esperad
un momento porque como os podéis
imaginar toda esta violencia por parte
de la policía no ha surgido de la nada
esta historia no es tan simple como
policía malvada contra unos pobres
manifestantes pacíficos atentos
los muertos y casi un centenar de
policías heridos en las protestas en
colombia por la reforma tributaria
decíamos que colombia tiene dos caras y
esta historia también tiene dos caras
por un lado es innegable que colombia
tiene un problema de brutalidad policial
para que os hagáis una idea las fuerzas
antidisturbios se utilizan armas como
ésta para reprimir las manifestaciones
esto que estáis viendo es el llamado be
no un lanzacohetes no letales para
protestas es decir un arma pensada en
principio para parar a los manifestantes
y matarlos el problema el problema es
que los chiles deben lanzarse de forma
parabólica sin embargo se han reportado
varios casos donde la policía la ha
usado para disparar directamente a los
ciudadanos y en estos casos el meno
puede ser letal y diréis pero por qué es
tan violenta la policía colombiana y
aquí es cuando llegamos a la parte
realmente interesante de este vídeo
puede que os sorprenda pero hay más
colombianos con pistolas que colombianos
pagando impuestos de la renta según la
fundación ideas para la paz casi 5
millones de colombianos tienen armas de
fuego ilegales todo esto es la
consecuencia de vivir en uno de los
países más violentos del mundo no sólo
hablamos de los narcotraficantes sino
también de grupos terroristas como las
farc
y un sinfín de grupos paramilitares de
hecho mucha gente dice que hay
infiltrados de estos grupos entre los
manifestantes
y diréis tienen razón pues lo cierto es
que en este momento no podemos confirmar
nada lo que sí podemos decir es que
tampoco es una teoría descabellada los
grupos terroristas no desaparecen de la
noche a la mañana y es más que razonable
pensar que algunos integrantes de estos
grupos se han unido a las protestas con
armas y todo esto explica que la policía
colombiana se parezca más a un ejército
que a una policía normal y no creéis que
exagero y en absoluto veréis en casi
todos los países del mundo la policía
forma parte del ministerio del interior-
en colombia sin embargo están en el
ministerio de defensa es decir que el
ejército y la policía están unidos en
este país mucho más que en cualquier
otro y eso explica noticias como estas
[Música]
más de 1000 hombres de las fuerzas
militares y el ejército llegarán a
reforzar la seguridad en cali y aquí es
cuando podemos entrar en el eterno
debate sobre quién tiene la razón
policía y ejército o manifestantes y la
respuesta es que ninguno pensadlo bien
cuál es el papel de la policía proteger
a los ciudadanos verdad es decir
proteger a los buenos y detener a los
malos pues bien en este caso estamos
viendo todo lo contrario los violentos
siguen en la calle convirtiendo a
colombia en uno de los países más
peligrosos del mundo sin embargo muchos
inocentes para la cárcel sufren torturas
o incluso mueren todo esto tiene un
nombre un nombre que genera pocos
titulares y que rara vez se convertiría
en trending topic en twitter no no es ni
policía asesina ni hashtag sos colombia
el auténtico nombre es mala gestión si
la policía y el ejército colombiano
necesitan modernizarse y diréis por qué
no lo hacen pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver y atentos porque esta es la parte
que seguro que muchos colombianos no
conocéis
[Música]
la doctrina damasco como hemos dicho en
colombia la policía y el ejército van de
la mano y diréis cómo es el ejército
colombiano pues hablamos de un ejército
especializado en una única cosa
operaciones especiales habéis oído bien
tras años de guerrillas en la selva el
ejército colombiano es experto en
operaciones en la selva por eso los
llamados comando jungla son
especialistas en encontrar a los narcos
que están perdidos por la selva el
problema de problemas de un ejército
tiene que ser capaz de hacer más cosas
por ejemplo la otan lleva años
intentando colaborar con el ejército
colombiano en operaciones
internacionales pero colombia todavía no
está preparada para eso y así es como en
el año 2011 surgió esta estrategia
colombia abandona la doctrina militar de
la guerra fría y se prepara para el
siglo 21 os presento la llamada doctrina
damasco probablemente nunca hayáis oído
hablar de ella aunque viváis en colombia
y eso es porque este tipo de noticias no
generan hashtags en twitter pero la
doctrina damasco era el intento de
colombia de modernizar su ejército y
diréis pero que es una doctrina militar
pues una doctrina militar es el conjunto
de manuales procesos estrategias y
tácticas que guía un ejército
es decir un ejército moderno como pueda
ser el de eeuu en israel no toma
decisiones de forma improvisada todo
está estandarizado en unos manuales y en
unos protocolos de esta forma todas las
unidades se pueden poner de acuerdo si
miráis un manual de doctrina militar
encontrareis que todo está explicado
hasta el más mínimo detalle por ejemplo
podréis ver cómo tiene que moverse un
avión de combate para disparar un
objetivo concreto
y diréis pero y todo esto que tiene que
ver con las protestas pues mucho porque
la doctrina nada más con no solo está
pensada para carreras convencionales
sino también para la protección civil
[Música]
concretamente incluye todo un protocolo
llamado la acción unificada este
protocolo indica perfectamente cómo se
pueden poner de acuerdo a la policía los
antidisturbios y el ejército indica a la
perfección cómo se pueden detectar a los
grupos violentos en una manifestación
sin atacar a los pacíficos
incluso explica con todo lujo de
detalles cómo entrenar a los soldados
para evitar violaciones de derechos
humanos es decir cómo evitar una
improvisación en una situación de riesgo
pensando así ponerlos por un momento en
la piel de un policía que está en mitad
de una manifestación de un día hay gente
armada cómo reacciona bien si os vais en
una situación así pues bien si os han
entrenado bien deberíais tener un
protocolo de actuación claro deberíais
saber que tenéis que hacer en ese
momento para no terminar teniendo que
elegir entre morir o matar y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando porque no ha
servido esta doctrina damasco para
evitar la ultraviolencia en las
protestas de colombia pues atentos
[Música]
el zapatero tomó posesión como
comandante del ejército pese a escándalo
en diciembre del año 2019 colombia
nombró un nuevo jefe del ejército el
general zapateiro y este es el
responsable de dar al traste con todo
este proceso de modernización del
ejército colombiano y aquí es donde
llegamos al debate realmente importante
en colombia por un lado tenemos a un
sector del ejército que quiere
modernizarse con estrategias y doctrinas
militares homologables con la otan por
el otro tenemos al sector más
tradicional que no quiere hacer el más
mínimo cambio este sector estaría
encabezado por el general zapateiro
conclusión colombia sigue teniendo un
ejército y una policía que no está
preparada para gestionar unas protestas
y todo esto significa que lo que podría
haber sido una simple protesta se haya
convertido en una guerra urbana una
guerra que ha puesto al gobierno contra
las cuerdas
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que habríamos visto una
situación diferente si el ejército
hubiera mantenido la doctrina damasco y
lo que es más importante cómo puede
colombia solucionar su problema fiscal
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual político sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse a este canal darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones y como siempre
no olvidéis que aquí en visual politics
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribirse a este canal y darle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]